bueno la idea de este libro salió de
nuestro deseo de mostrar que la genómica
no es una tecnología solo para países en
desarrollo es una tecnología que se
puede aplicar básicamente en todos los
rincones del mundo para mejorar la
calidad de la atención a los pacientes y
la calidad de la medicina y para llegar
a una medicina más personalizada y de
mayor precisión
en américa latina tenemos todavía muchos
retos aunque aquí en el libro mostramos
muchos ejemplos de aplicación de la
genómica médica en américa latina en
particular hay retos aún en cuanto a la
educación del personal de salud para el
uso de estas nuevas tecnologías hay
retos también
en cuanto al costo de estas nuevas
tecnologías y hay retos sobre todo en la
capacidad de tener el personal
calificado que pueda usar estas nuevas
tecnologías de la genómica
nuestro sueño de todas formas queda que
sea la genómica para cada una de las
naciones y no únicamente para países en
desarrollo en canadá por ejemplo hay
muchísimos avances que se están haciendo
actualmente en genómica cada es uno de
los líderes en la el uso de la genómica
lo que llamamos la medicina de precisión
una medicina mucho más precisa con el
uso de estas nuevas tecnologías estamos
liderando en el campo de la oncología
las enfermedades raras y canadá como
digo está avanzando a pasos agigantados
en este campo